in Strasbourg European Parliament for
this very important debate with the
members of the European Parliament on
the future of the European Union for us
is very important to know the German
position on the most important issues on
the future of our union we know the
position of the European Parliament we
know the position of the European
Commission
but for paving the way for a better
Europe we need to change Europe but
should be a big mistake to destroy
Europe we want to be European also in
the next year's European Parliament want
more power we are the only one
we are the only one European institution
directly elected directly by the
citizens on the budget we want to decide
before the European election we want to
increase the budget from one point one
to one point three
we want all resources on immigration the
other important issue we want to
cooperate with the council you want to
achieve good solution on Dublin reform
it's possible to achieve an agreement
before the end of this year this and
also if you want to achieve good
solution on immigration we need to
invest more in Africa we need a plan for
Africa we need more money in Africa
against climate change
against terrorism against poverty in
favor growth not a new colonization but
the new modern cooperation between
Europe and Africa
for this we need also in European
foreign policy within European defense
this isn't very important for us this
very important for the future of the
European Union Thank You Chancellor for
being here and you have the floor
[Applause]
yeah better casual yeah yeah the catches
AI it's open together happy the
President of the European Parliament
dear Antonio Tajani president of the
European Commission
jean-claude Juncker ladies and gentlemen
members of the European Parliament
commissioners ladies and gentlemen over
fifty years ago about a Haj Dean the
German president at the time described
European unification as an exemplary
experimenter and this was ten years
before the first direct elections to the
European Parliament at that time the
European community was still in its
infancy
a lot of the achievements such as
Sherman the internal market with
visionary projects but the foundations
had been laid and hundreds of years of
wars and dictatorships for the citizens
of Europe were over and for the first
time they had a stable and peaceful
future ahead of them today I'm here with
joy but also with gratitude in front of
the greatest Parliament of the world
we have 751 members from 28 countries
that representing over half a million
people approximately 7 percent of the
world's population in this house we feel
the heart of democracy beating carried
out by 28 countries and this describes
something which is so important about
Europe its diversity this is one of the
greatest strengths of us in Europe
because despite our diversity we have a
commitment to unity to compromise that
despite our different origins despite
our different opinions what we are doing
here is to come to results which are to
the benefit of our community it's a year
since I last uh spoke to this house in
2007 Germany took over the presidency of
the council I talked at that time about
the diversity which brings us together
which does not separate us about the
peace which we have to defend about the
fact that we in Europe need to breathe
good air I talked about freedom and
diversity being connected in Europe I
spoke about tolerance I also mentioned
the fact that tolerance is the soul of
Europe it is an indispensable basic
value for we Europeans and last year we
have experienced how much the world has
changed and we have experienced also how
the soul of Europe is being affected the
global political economic and
technological challenge which we have to
face moving forward at a more and more
rapid pace we have experienced a series
of crisis we have experienced
international terrorism violent armed
conflicts and migration
movements which have had a serious
impact on us in Europe and of course
digital progress has considerably
changed our lifestyles we are
experiencing the results of climate
change and all we are seeing our values
caught into question the United Kingdom
is a country which is soon going to
leave the European Union and this is a
deep wound and I think that turning now
to Michel Barnier here for the work that
he has done I think that we can all
applaud him for it dear members of the
European Parliament we are all realising
that it is very difficult ever more
difficult to balance development but
also we are experiencing the fact that
it's becoming more and more difficult to
speak alone on the global stage to put
our interest forwards and thus it
becomes even more important that we
stand side-by-side as Europeans and thus
the European Union more than ever needs
to respect both the interests of its own
members and of others we need to
understand that tolerance is the soul of
Europe that is as essential component of
what makes us Europeans and that only
together with you can we develop her to
ensure that we also take account of the
interests and needs of others as well as
of our own
that brings us to the core of European
solidarity without which we cannot be
successful and this solidarity is based
on tolerance and it represents our
strength as Europeans which we can find
nowhere else there are three reasons for
this first of all solidarity is a
universal value we have to work for each
other it is essential requisite for
every operation for families for
villages for sports associations as well
as for a community such as the European
Union solidarity is a component of the
European treaty it is a central feature
of our values it is a cornerstone of
Europe it supports the economic
development and also helps us combat
youth unemployment we faced either with
a terrorist attacks or other attacks on
our values we have the European crisis
the so called umbrella which was to
cover us and help us and help to solve
our financial problems we have a few
examples here which demonstrate how
individual countries of European Union
and citizens of the European Union are
in difficulties but they do not stand
alone so we have a few examples of this
but on the other side of the coin we
have national issues which always have
an impact on the community as a whole
therefore secondly solidarity is always
linked to commitments of the community
and the principles based on the rule of
law in my country the rights of the
Opposition and civil society are
adversely affected if press freedom is
curtailed but state based on the rule of
law and the rule of law
in general is something which is not
just national but is for all of us all
of us throughout Europe for Europe of
course can only operate properly as a
community which is based on law when
those laws are applied if individually
we try to deal with our problems
then we compromise the strength and
stability of our euro because our common
currency can only work properly if each
individual member shares the
responsibility who actually tries to
jeopardize the agreement of Europe on
individual issues for example human
rights policies or others is adversely
affecting the entire European foreign
policy and Europe can only be a voice to
the world if it works together and that
means that solidarity always means that
we have to overcome national egoism and
I am well aware of this I am from
Germany and I know that this has not
always been the case for example in the
years before 2015 we took far too long
to realize that the issue of refugees
was an issue for the whole of Europe and
not just for Germany and in order to
understand this we have to realize that
this is a common European task and
thirdly using solidarity for everybody
means that we have to deal with our own
interests with a view to others we have
to respect others but this is not
something that contradicts looking after
our own interests quite to the contrary
for example we need to work
to combat migration problems with third
countries this is an issue which mr.
tierney also just brought up we have to
at the same time ensure that people on
the spot have living conditions improved
because it is often because of difficult
conditions at home that they flee
towards Europe now looking at climate
change this has economic and social
consequences it is crucial that we
tackle this it's a useful for Europe if
industry and threshold countries produce
less greenhouse gas and our whole system
becomes creamer but it is also important
for all Europeans if they develop better
stability within the eurozone it's
useful for all Europeans if everybody
participates in protection against a
climate change it's going to help her
all Europeans if we tackle together
those who are affected by immigration
accepting refugees by different member
states on the basis of their democratic
development and their own histories has
triggered off different reactions
solidarity means that we should do
absolutely our utmost to find a common
approach to tackle this and other
subsequent results our work together as
a community
so solidarity is a universal basic value
it is a responsibility for our community
and solidarity is also in our own
interests the interests of our well
being so unity and determination are key
for us I would like to raise three
issues which I feel are particularly
important first of all foreign and
security policy as Europeans we notice
that we can develop end in
when we work together only a stronger
Europe is going to be able to defend its
values and interests world wide and the
times when we could rely on others our
posture this means that we as Europeans
now have to really take our faith fully
into our own hands if we want to defend
our community and that means that in the
long term we in Europe have to develop
our foreign policy more we need to think
this through we need to try and do
without people working on their own
behalf for the benefit of our citizens I
have suggested that we establish
European a Security Council with
changing presidencies of the Member
States where decisions can be taken more
rapidly we have to create a European
intervention force so that we can tackle
issues immediately on the ground we have
already achieved cooperation in the
military sphere that is good and we are
going to continue to support this but
what we should do and this is really
important if we look at the developments
of the past years we have to work on a
vision of one day creating a real true
European army
[Applause]
okay Janklow Lemcke some years ago
already said that a common european army
would show the world that they will
never again be war in europe I'm not
saying anything against NATO of course
not
we can be a good supplement to NATO
I will leave a colleague and run polling
but colleagues it would be a lot easier
to cooperate with us if we have more
than 160 different weapon systems and
the US has only 50 or 60 and if we had
we realized that all the different
instances need training and education
and if we could work together and pool
our efforts together then we could work
together with NATO with a European army
please stand up please
I'm really pleased about this this is
great I'm annoying some people are in a
parliament mines I'm at 3 o'clock so we
need the common development of armament
systems within Europe and this of course
means a difficult task for the Federal
Republic of Germany because we are going
to have to develop also a common
European arms exports policy ladies and
gentlemen let's now come on to the
economic issues this is the basis of our
strength and is the prerequisite for our
position in the world because if we're
not economically strong we're not going
to be politically strong and I am very
pleased to have looked at at jean-claude
yonkers plan the investment fund which
has had a considerable impact over the
past few years and has 500 billion euros
invested up until 2020 350 are already
in the pipeline and a good program for
better investment is something which is
really important we've been working on
it for a long time and I think we should
be talking about this now the 350
million a real contribution to improving
prosperity in Europe and of course to
stable and a stable Europe with
wellbeing for its citizens also needs a
stable economy we need to develop our
part our monetary policy better we're
working on a banking Union Germany and
France have already made statements on
this and I think that we need to link
very closely to the midterm mff on this
we have to look at responsibility and
control a banking Union and then later a
European insurance system and this is
something which is going to reduce the
risks of national country of national
country governments because of course
what we're looking at here is something
which is two sides of the same coin but
here the European Council at least
Germany is on board together with France
is going to be able to make more
progress we've had intensive discussions
over the past few days on digital
taxation for example you've participated
in that I know Germany is not asking
whether we feel that this goes without
saying but the question is how are we
going to do this and I think that what
is important democratically is to take
the comments of the Commission on board
and to look at how in an international
context we can also get an international
solution we are looking at minimum
taxation but if that doesn't work we
can't wait forever we are going to have
to work on it in Europe independently if
we're honest with ourselves and if we
look into the future and think about our
lifestyle and well-being we have to
realize that it is not the same today as
it was
100 or 150 years ago that inventions
always came from Europe a lot of
inventions and innovations now come from
Asia and from the United States and then
of course we have to put the question to
ourselves as to how on our continent we
are going to determine the mobility of
the future we have to look at the fact
that for example Chinese companies are
investing in Germany that's fine but I
want to make sure that we are stronger
in Europe and that we want to be able to
master the innovative technologies of
the future we have got the European
instruments for this we've got
everything before us we've got to look
at quantum computing we've got to look
at the development of artificial
intelligence and this is still possible
because we have a strong industrial
basis in Europe that we can build upon
we have to avail ourselves of that and
research and innovation are therefore
central focal points for our future
well-being and the third area colleagues
which I should like to refer to is
immigration and refugees during our
crisis we had to overcome many hurdles
and come to a common solution but we've
been successful in many areas but the
issue of immigration is something which
is not yet brought Europe together as I
would like it to this is a real core
topic an issue which reflects our
relationship with our neighbors and
we've got to find common approaches we
have made progress we all agree that we
need a European Border Protection force
but perhaps saying that we have a
Schengen area with a free movement and
then start working on who comes in who
comes out then we find
that we are infringing the principles of
that once again it's true that we've
developed Frontex the Commission's
proposals in my opinion are good but if
everybody wants to retain their
international responsibilities and
doesn't want to give anything away they
can be as big as good as they want to be
but they won't be able to do what they
have to we have to work on this together
and we also have to think through
development age economic development and
how we can participate they have
excellent results compared to what we
had two years ago because individual
member states with the Commission have
been working in individual member states
and have achieved more than they would
do individually I think we can learn a
lot from that but this is just part of
the way down the road and I think
therefore we also need to develop a
European a common European Asylum policy
if everybody takes decisions
individually then nobody can be
surprised but countries from a
particular country know about a certain
country immediately and then we get to
secondary migration we have to make an
effort to ensure that we have the same
common playing field for the internal
market even on issues as such as right
to asylum and humanitarian
responsibilities we have to deal with
some we have to deal with these issues
together we have to have a common policy
ladies and gentlemen I just given you
three examples of many that I could have
come up with and the fact that I have
really hit the nail on the head is
demonstrated by the protest noises that
I've been hearing I think that what
people want is that Europe
really tackles these difficult problems
these burning problems we need to tackle
the issues which are facing us but this
doesn't mean that Europe has to be
everywhere not every problem in Europe
is a European problem solidarity means
that Europe deals with things where it
is necessary and when it does so it does
that in a decisive effective manner
I think Europa gives us our best chance
to lasting peace lasting well-being and
a safe and secure future in Paris at the
invitation of the French presidency when
we think that the first world war came
to an end a hundred years ago
once again we should think through what
happens if countries don't have a
respect for each other
and what happens if countries and the
associations the League of Nations in
those days collapses and therefore we
should not give up our European
opportunity because if we do we shall
adversely affect not just ourselves but
the younger generation nationalism and
egotism should no longer have a position
in Europe but tolerance and solidarity
represent our common future and
colleagues it is well well worth
fighting for them thank you
[Applause]
Navaro Laura I know medical mission
repair our president Asian cold and now
I should like to call on Sean Claud you
include the president to the Commission
miss you savvy investor be embedded in
REO inquest I will afford to see the vet
here in the room was it done the
president in
zip it president Chancellor addy
Wrangler I have convinced of everything
that you have said here is correct
I'm very impressed by all of the combat
segments I'm just surprised that some
people are not here to listen to what
you've had to say standing ovations for
the Chancellor are easy just began
saying the very same things so thanks to
this house to have discovered the same
dignity of equal nations in Europe
monsieur le president of c or c Nokomis
a Sawbuck Ubu president there are also a
lot more commissioners here than they
were for some of the other speeches as
well
miss miss Europe Asia dawn president I
was very pleased to hear what you said
about multilateralism multilateralism is
one of the core values of the European
Union and what you said it really goes
to the heart of what the European
Commission has been proposing and I
think there was a great deal of applause
today and a lot more than I got when I
spoke in October 2014 and I think that
history will prove here right and not
everyone here has always seen things
that way but a York or you were quite
right not to close the borders
[Applause]
that's yes the there there could be some
more applause on that point then we've
just heard now on the issue of brexit
we're swimming in the same water I will
just repeat that we do not want to
punish the United Kingdom the United
Kingdom exactly the opposite but we have
to respect the vote in the UK best of it
in the interest of written in interest
of view of the European Union we are not
in aggressive mood when it comes to the
future relations with Britain do you
open Union the continent has to
recognize that Britain starting in 39
was playing a major role when it came to
the Liberty and the freedom of this
continent we are grateful for that but
this
[Applause]
this is not the reason to live to live
the great history between the islands
and European Union in fact I do think
that the leaf is a tragic and historical
error a mistake and we have to do the
best out of it and the European
Commission together with Michel Barnier
is moving into that direction the switch
the feel what was important I mean of
course everything you said was important
but I was struck by what you said about
Africa Africa remains not a problem but
it is an issue for Africans it's a great
opportunity for Africans and for Europe
we need to work together in solidarity
and friendship the Commission has made
proposals with regard to the external
plan and we should be building on those
proposal I appreciate everything that
people say in favour of greater
solidarity but working with Africa is
not charity it is being part of a
movement but not wanting to do favors
for Africa we need a partnership with
Africa between equals Africa it doesn't
depend on us we also depend on Africa
and so for that reason we need to do
more for Africa so all in all Chancellor
Angela I think the comments that you've
made really go to the heart of what we
need to do and perhaps there could be a
little bit more support
for all of the brave initiatives by the
Commission on immigration on Africa on
the euro reform and if you do even more
than you have until now you will be even
greater than you are and we would
welcome that
[Applause]
Rashidah they select user elite system
have a registration electronica I'm now
going to closer the system of electronic
voting requests for catch the eye so now
we're going to have the intervention of
the different leaders of the political
groups first of all meant word Weber on
behalf of the European People's Party
lyrically Chancellor president ladies
and gentlemen if I could quote the unity
of Europe was the dream of not very many
people